range indeed are the ways of Hollywood
this year for the first time in the
history of the Academy a young woman is
up for an award for putting her head on
a pillow here's miss Doris Day
yours should come a long way since our
radio days congratulations on your
nomination oh thank you Bob you know I
really owe it all to you because you
gave me my first lines on stage mother
nature helped a little too but you know
something you taught me how to work to
an audience and how to read a line how
to wait for a lab yeah wait wait as soon
as they give little bread they get awful
crusty Doris I thought you were with
rock tonight would you believe it that
man is still on the phone you'll have to
fake if the envelope is waiting thank
you in many cases long after a motion
picture has played itself out and has
even faded from the Late Late shows of
television its songs live on making the
world a little bit brighter for all of
us you have heard the five songs
nominated for an Oscar and immortality
and the winner is heigh-ho
thank you
one of the greatest priorities I ever
heard